So first it was a full here and a full there
by appointment.
Bernie Sanders may be sort of getting close
to leading nationally sporadically.
Then it was more polls by larger margins than
within the margin of error.
And what we have today is Bernie Sanders leading
in the last four national polls in a row and
in seven of the last eight national polls.
This is an analysis of the polling not of
policy of any particular candidate.
We also are going to talk about some delegate
math, which I think is very important to understand.
Now, this is in, in only um, one of these
polls.
Does Bernie Sanders have 30% support?
But I'll tell you how that can be sort of
deceiving when it comes to the delegate math
in a moment.
First, let's take a look at the polls.
The last four polls released recently are
NBC survey USA.
That NPR, PBS Marist poll we discussed earlier
this week, and economist you gov Bernie is
leading in all four of those.
The smallest margin is for the largest margin
is 12.
Now if you go back further and you look at
the last eight poles instead of the last four,
you will see that Bernie is leading in seven
of the last eight polls and Bernie is in that
eighth poll where he's not winning.
He's only down three putting him squarely
within the margin of error in six of the seven
polls that Bernie leads, Joe Biden is in second
place in one of those, Michael Bloomberg is
in second place.
Now, one of the things we've been discussing
is this asymmetrical fight for the democratic
nomination, which requires 50% plus one delegates.
That means that of the 3,980 delegates, 50%
plus one would be 1,991 so 39 80 half plus
one is 1991 last week we did this story where
I explained Bernie has to get 50% plus one.
Why?
Because most likely if Bernie does not get
50% plus one, the superdelegates who will
be allowed to vote in the second round at
the democratic national convention in July
in Milwaukee, I believe it is, will most likely
select someone else.
In other words, if Bernie falls just short
in the first round and all of the superdelegates
come in, the most likely scenario is they
will all rally around.
Say for example, Pete, Buddha judge or Michael
Bloomberg or whoever, we don't know how that
establishment situation's going to shake out
yet, but it's not going to be behind Bernie.
So Bernie to win needs 50% plus one delegates.
Now he needs to start getting a majority of
the delegates in primaries and so far he's
not doing that.
But if you want to stop Bernie, you need only
split the vote enough.
Divide the rest of the non Bernie vote enough
so that nobody gets 50% plus one and then
superdelegates can end up deciding on that
second round of voting at the convention.
So it's an asymmetrical battle that is taking
place, but there's something that's less obvious
about the numbers.
You might look at the numbers and you might
see, Oh, I don't know, Bernie's averaging
27.3 in recent polls.
So if we just run those numbers, there's through
39 80 delegates, and if he gets 27.3% of those
delegates, that's 1,086 delegates.
That's way short.
That's barely half of the 1991 that Bernie
needs to secure the nomination, and you would
be correct in that analysis.
But remember that in most primaries, you need
15% to qualify for any delegates.
It's what's called the viability threshold.
Now it's done at the district level, but to
simplify our math today, imagine that it's
a 15% state viability threshold.
Let's look at an example.
California is a good example.
California is worth 416 delegates, huge population,
very important state where you can pick up
a bunch of delegates.
Right now, Bernie has about 26% support in
California, but there are only three candidates
who have at least 15% or more, and those are
Bernie Biden and Warren.
So if these are the voting results in California,
Bernie's 26% of the vote would get them almost
39% of the delegates because that's the portion
of the viable candidate support that he has.
So you can get 26% of the vote and 39% of
the delegates.
Now, you would rightly be saying, hold on
a second, David, that's still not 50% and
Bernie needs 50% plus one and of course you're
correct, but it's far closer than the 26%
of the vote that Bernie has.
In this hypothetical example, in a state where
it's, you know, Bernie 25 someone else 17
and then nobody else gets the 15% Bernie in
that scenario would have 25% of the raw vote,
but he would get up, get about 60% of the
delegates.
So remember it, this is not exact because
we're talking about what is usually district
level calculations and applying them to Insta
entire States.
But the principle is what matters.
You might say, if Bernie only gets 30% of
the vote, he couldn't possibly get percent
of the delegates.
You're probably right, but there is a way
to make the numbers work and it's conceivable
that if he can get 35 or 38% support that
that would actually get them the 50% plus
one delegates.
You've got to go through a number of different
scenarios, but case in point, even though
Bernie is polling 20 to 30 in most States,
he still according to five 38 the most likely
of the candidates to get to that 50% plus
one threshold.
A five 38 says that there is a 41% chance
that Bernie gets the fold number of delegates
that he needs.
Uh, no one getting the number they need is
at 37%.
So there's a 78% chance according to five
38 that it's either no one or Bernie, all
of the other candidates splitting that remaining
22% of the scenarios.
And then of course, the next point at which
we will see the dynamics of this race, possibly
change will be tonight because Michael Bloomberg
will be debating Bernie and the other candidates.
Let's
talk
about
that next.